*Titelmelodie*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Herzlich willkommen
zum mit Abstand besten Q&A,
dass es jemals
bei schönschlau gegeben hat.
- Aber das ist doch das einzige Q&A.
Dieses Q&A ist für alle,
die sich fragen, wer ist eigentlich
diese Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim und wie
spricht man ihren Nachnamen aus?
Wie man meinen Nachnamen ausspricht,
habt ihr jetzt zwar nicht gefragt,
aber es ist mit Abstand
die häufigste Frage,
die ich im Real Life
gestellt bekomme.
Nguyen Name.
Schätzungsweise 40 % aller
Vietnamesen tragen diesen Namen.
Und da sehr viele Asiaten hier in
Deutschland auch Vietnamesen sind,
wird es höchste Zeit, dass man mal
weiß, wie man Nguyen ausspricht.
Nguyen wird zu ähnlich ausgesprochen
wie das Nürn von Nürnberg.
Statt Mai Thi Nürnberg
sagt man einfach MaiThi Nguyen-Kim.
Nicht so schwer, oder?
Die ein bisschen sprachlich
begabteren, können,
das NG versuchen auszusprechen -
"Nn".
Eigentlich ist es genauso
wie das NG im Deutschen,
nur hier haben wir
es immer als Endung.
Enduunng! Nguyen, Nguyen.
Wenn ihr das so aussprechen könnt -
ist das schon ziemlich gut.
In Wirklichkeit ist Vietnamesisch
eine tonale Sprache: Nguyen.
Es gibt die nordvietnamesische
Aussprache: Nguyen.
Und es gibt die südvietnamesische
Was? Nguyen. Nguyen-Kim.
Soviel dazu, das wollte ich
nur mal kurz loswerden.
Die häufigste Frage,
die ich gestellt bekomme im Leben.
Jetzt kommen wir zu euren Fragen.
Alter Freund, dieser Sendung.
*Musik*
Natürlich ein glücklicher Nacktmull.
Vielen Dank für eure Glückwünsche und
Spaßwünsche für die Flitterwochen.
Ihr wolltet außerdem wissen,
wie es war.
Es war sehr schön.
Wer mir auf Instagram folgt,
weiß, wir waren in der Sonne.
Dreieinhalb Wochen in Neuseeland
und dann noch 3 Tage in Sydney.
Ich bin seit neuestem
relativ aktiv bei Instagram.
Ich hab das so ein bisschen
für mich entdeckt.
Vor meiner YouTube-Zeit war ich
eigentlich nicht besonders aktiv
auf sämtlichen Social-Media-Kanälen.
Außer vielleicht auf Facebook.
Aber bei Instagram macht mir
jetzt ziemlich viel Spaß.
Und der Grund, warum ich so viel
Werbung für Instagram mache,
ist einfach, dass ich es jetzt
für mich entdeckt habe.
Das ist mein privater Account.
Ich werde nicht dafür bezahlt.
Wie auch schon spekuliert wurde.
Ich find's auch einfach
ganz praktisch,
um auch ab und zu mal ein paar
Minerannouncenments zu machen.
Was so ansteht auch
außerhalb von YouTube.
Z.B. hat mich jemand gefragt,
ob ich noch Science-Slams mache?
Und ob man mich
irgendwo mal live sehen kann.
Ich mach jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt
so die klassischen Science-Slams,
nicht mehr so oft oder kaum noch.
Aber ich gebe viele Vorträge,
die sind teilweise auch
science-slam-artig.
Wissenschaftliches Thema -
aber möglichst unterhaltsam
und verständlich aufbereitet.
Und diese Vorträge gebe ich immer mal
wieder überall in Deutschland.
Und das kündige ich
dann auch an auf Instagram.
In den Storys zum Beispiel.
Und wenn ihr dann in der Nähe seid,
in der Stadt seid,
könnt ihr natürlich vorbeikommen
und mir zu hören.
Und mir hallo sagen
oder mir einmal High-Five geben.
Hier hinten ist das
Secret-Life of Scientist Studio.
Herzlich willkommen!
Dann habe ich hier quasi
die weiße schönschlau-Wand.
Blablabla.
Seit neuestem habe ich
noch so 2 Screens,
die man hoch
und runter ziehen kann.
Freunde der Sonne.
Science-News!
Hier nehme ich
die meisten Videos auf,
bzw. auch teilweise in meinem
Wohnzimmer oder meiner Küche,
was ihr ja auch schon gesehen habt,
hier bei schönschlau.
Ob ich noch
irgendwelche Instrumente spiele?
Außer Ukulele?
Ich habe früher natürlich
Geige und Klavier gespielt,
wie es sich gehört für eine Asiatin.
Geige und Klavier
ist tatsächlich sehr stereotypisch
und ich möchte unterstreichen,
dass meine Eltern mich nicht
dazu gezwungen haben.
Ich wollte früher alle
möglichen Instrumente spielen.
Interessanterweise wollte ich
eine Zeit lang immer Oboe spielen.
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, warum.
Geige und Klavier ist es geworden.
Mit Geige hab ich angefangen -
unglaublich undankbares Instrument.
Klavier habe ich geliebt,
ich habe sehr viel gespielt,
während ich in der Schule war.
Ich hab sogar
kurzzeitig mal überlegt,
ob ich Klavier studieren soll.
Als ich 16 war, oder so, hat meine
Klavierlehrerin zu mir gesagt:
"Mai es wird langsam Zeit,
zu überlegen,
ob du Pianistin werden willst.
"Weil wenn, ist jetzt
allerhöchste Eisenbahn,
um die Schule zu wechseln".
Ich hätte dann irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht,
nach Hamburg
oder sonst wo ziehen müssen.
Und auf so'n Musikgymnasium
gehen müssen.
Aber das war mir zu viel.
Es ist halt generell so, dass ich
nicht gerne nur eine Sache mache,
bis zum Erbrechen.
Das ist 'ne schlechte Voraussetzung,
wenn man Pianist werden möchte.
Also wenn man Pianist werden möchte,
muss man, glaube ich,
den ganzen Tag üben.
Und das wollte ich halt nicht.
Übrigens, vielen Dank für euer
vieles Lob für meine Gesangseinlagen.
I just want you to subscribe...
Ich nehme die dankend
und demütig zur Kenntnis.
Aber übertreibt mal nicht.
Ihr müsstet mich mal
unter der Dusche hören.
Das klingt gut!
*Musik: Whitney Houston:
I will always love you*
Aber mal im Ernst,
ich würde sehr gerne mal
ein Science-Musikvideo machen.
Ich bräuchte dazu nur Unterstützung.
D.h., Marti Fischer, Phil Laude,
wenn ihr das seht, call me.
Schaust du Breaking Bad
und The Big Bang Theoriy?
Zu Breaking Bad bin ich
immer noch nicht gekommen.
Ich bin 'ne schlechte Chemikerin.
Und Big Bang Theory - ich hab da
ab und zu mal reingeschaut.
Also, ich hab nichts dagegen -
aber es gibt mir irgendwie nichts.
Ich find's einfach nicht witzig.
Viele haben mich gefragt, wie ich
eigentlich auf Chemie gekommen bin.
Wahrscheinlich, im Gegensatz
zu vielen anderen Chemikern,
war Chemie jetzt nicht immer
my one and only love gewesen.
Also, ich fand's
schon immer geil, keine Frage.
Aber ich hab mich damals
für sehr viele verschiedene Sachen
interessiert.
Das tue ich eigentlich immer noch.
Und entsprechend wollte ich auch sehr
viele verschiedene Sachen studieren.
Und es fiel mir relativ schwer,
da 'ne Entscheidung zu treffen.
Irgendwann hab ich mich
zunächst mal für allgemein
Naturwissenschaften entschieden.
Weil ich dachte, Naturwissenschaften
kann man nicht so ohne weiteres
allein als Hobby verfolgen.
Im Gegensatz zu Sprachen,
Musik oder Politik.
Deswegen dachte ich, wenn ich nicht
Naturwissenschaften studiere,
dann werde ich bald gar nichts
Naturwissenschaften zu tun haben.
Und das konnte ich natürlich
auf gar keinen Fall zulassen.
Dann hab ich noch sehr,
sehr lange überlegt,
ob ich Chemie
oder Physik studieren möchte.
Darüber hab ich mir wochenlang,
monatelang den Kopf zerbrochen.
Am Ende hab ich mich
für Chemie entschieden.
Ich find's einfach immer noch total
abgefahren, dass man einfach
Dinge, Sachen, Wirkstoffe,
was weiß ich, Wirkstoffe bis hin
zu Handyhüllen aus Polymeren,
äh Quatsch, aus Molekülen
selbst machen kann.
Selbst herstellen kann.
Aber Physik hätte mir am Ende
genauso viel Spaß gemacht,
da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Und diese ganzen Grenzen
zwischen den Naturwissenschaften
sind sowieso reine Ansichtssache.
Ja, auch. Aber ich finde sie
vor allem auch sehr faszinierend.
Man muss schon wertschätzen,
wie durchdacht,
bis ins kleinste Detail, diese ganzen
Verschwörungstheorien sind.
Und wie viel Zeit
und Gedankenarbeit die Leute,
die sich damit beschäftigen,
investieren.
Fast schon wie ein Wissenschaftler.
Nur halt falsch.
Wusstet ihr zum Beispiel,
dass die Flat Earth Society,
also die Leute, die denken,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist,
das nicht von allen Planeten denken.
Nein.
Der Mars zum Beispiel ist eine Kugel,
denn bei Mars kann man das ja
offensichtlich ganz leicht
nachweisen, dass er eine Kugel ist,
im Gegensatz zur Erde.
Ich hab noch nie länger über
die Flat Earth Society nachgedacht.
Aber als ich das gehört habe,
dachte ich mir,
was glauben die
eigentlich noch alles?
Gibt's noch weitere Scheiben-Planeten
oder ist die Erde
die einzige Scheibe?
Vor allem was ist unter der Scheibe?
Dreht sich die Scheibe irgendwie?
Bewegt die sich auch?
Was passiert am Rand der Scheibe?
Kann man da hinreisen,
also kann man dahin fliegen -
oder warum hat das noch keiner
gemacht? Ich hab so viele Fragen.
Nein! Also no offence - Bäume. Die
besten Tiere sind natürlich Quokkas.
Eigentlich gibt es 5 beste Tiere,
könnt ihr euch gerne mitschreiben,
das ist ein Fakt.
Die 5 besten Tiere in keiner
besonderen Reihenfolge sind:
Pinguine,
Quokkas,
Wombats,
Roborovski Hamster,
und Pfeifhasen.
(pfeift)
Diese Frage
muss ich nicht beantworten,
denn die habt ihr
schon beantwortet.
42, Jesus, Kekse!
Ist der Sinn des Lebens nicht jener,
den du persönlich deinem Leben gibst?
42.
Wenn jetzt noch jemand 42 antwortet,
dann haben wir n=3
und die Antwort
ist statistisch signifikant. 42.
Der gute alte Manuel Grill, Tach,
fragt unter anderem,
was Quantenverschränkung ist.
Aber wozu soll ich mir
die Mühe machen, das zu erklären?
Darum kümmern sich ja schon
Julia und "Nein Machichnicht".
Sehr viele wollten wissen, an was ich
gerade forsche oder geforscht habe.
Oder um was es
in meiner Doktorarbeit ging.
In meiner Forschung habe ich
mit Drug Delivery angefangen.
Dabei geht es ausnahmsweise
nicht um Drogen und Chrystal Meth.
Und übrigens ja,
natürlich können Chemiker,
oder kann jeder ausgebildete
Chemiker, Drogen kochen.
Es ist nur manchmal
ein bisschen kompliziert,
an gewisse Ausgangsstoffe
dranzukommen,
die schon dafür bekannt sind,
dass sie für Drogen verwendet werden.
Aber zurück zu Drug Delivery.
Es gibt ja zum Beispiel
Krebsmedikamente,
die durchaus wirksam sind - aber
die gleichzeitig, oder meistens,
auch gleichzeitig schädlich sind.
Denn Krebsmedikamente
sollen ja Krebszellen zerstören.
Wie kriegt man das hin,
ohne gesunde Zellen zu schaden?
Es gibt hier verschiedene Ansätze,
die Chemiker verfolgen,
in der Krebstherapie.
Manche Chemiker versuchen
den Wirkstoff selbst so zu verändern,
dass er selektiver wird.
Andere versuchen den Wirkstoff
cleverer zu verpacken.
Und das sind in der Regel
Polymer-Chemiker.
Polymere sind lange Molekülketten,
mit denen Polymer-Chemiker,
wie ich, dann Transportvehikel
oder Verpackungen herstellen können,
für die Wirkstoffe.
Und zwar auf dem Nanometer-Maßstab.
Also es geht hier nicht um
makroskopische Pillen oder Tabletten.
Sondern der Wirkstoff
soll eingespritzt werden
und dann durch die Blutbahn
zum Beispiel zum Krebs gelangen.
Diese Verpackung muss
verschiedene Aufgaben erfüllen,
muss den Wirkstoff
vor dem Immunsystem schützen,
damit er nicht einfach vom Körper
entsorgt wird und niemals da ankommt,
wo er ankommen will.
Die Verpackung muss die Krebszellen
erkennen und unterscheiden können
von gesunden Zellen.
Muss da andocken können, irgendwie.
Muss den Wirkstoff in die Krebszellen
einschleusen können
und dann natürlich in den Zellen
wieder freisetzen.
D.h., die Verpackung
darf jetzt nicht so stabil sein,
dass der Wirkstoff
nie wieder freigesetzt wird.
Mega schwierig, mega spannend,
sehr cooles Forschungsgebiet.
So fing meine Forschung an.
Die habe ich dann auch
in die Doktorarbeit mitgenommen
und eigentlich war ich gerade dabei
ein neues Polymer für Drug Delivery
zu entwickeln, als sich plötzlich
zufällig feststellte,
dass dieses Polymer ein Gel bildet.
Gele kennt ihr auch aus dem Alltag:
Haargel oder Wackelpudding.
Ein irgendwie
festes aber doch weiches
und auch elastisches Material, das
zu großen Teil aus Wasser besteht,
wie ein Schwamm.
Hydrogel nennt man das.
Diese Hydrogele
sind deswegen so interessant
für biomedizinische Anwendungen,
weil sie in ihren
mechanischen Eigenschaften
ganz ähnlich sein können
zu biologischem Gewebe.
Deswegen werden Hydrogele
auch als Basis verwendet, als Gerüst,
um darauf Zellen zu züchten und
so künstliche Gewebe herzustellen.
Tissue Engineering
nennt man dieses Anwendungsgebiet.
Ist auf den 1. Blick ein ganz
anderes Gebiet als Drug Delivery.
Chemisch gesehen aber sehr ähnlich.
Also das Polymer muss bioverträglich
sein, es muss wasserlöslich sein,
es muss funktional sein, also
auf seine Umgebung reagieren können.
Und so kam ich dann in diesen Tissue
Engineering Bereich und hab mich
jetzt in meiner Doktorarbeit,
oder die letzten Jahre
meiner Doktorarbeit,
damit beschäftigt, dieses Polymer,
dieses neue Polymer, zu entwickeln,
mit dem man dann ein Gel
herstellen kann,
dass hoffentlich irgendwann
als Basis für künstliches Gewebe
eingesetzt werden könnte.
Jetzt bin ich seit letztem Jahr
fertig mit der Doktorarbeit.
Und seit ich das bin,
fragen sich viele,
was ich jetzt eigentlich
genau mache. Außer YouTube.
Nach der Doktorarbeit habe ich mir
erst mal ein Sabbatjahr
von der Forschung genommen.
Also ein Jahr Auszeit,
um das mit Funk zu probieren.
Weil Funk zufälligerweise
genau mit dem Ende
meiner Doktorarbeit zusammenfiel.
Diejenigen, die mich
schon länger schauen und auch
das Secret Life of Scientist kennen,
wissen, dass das damals
sehr überraschend kam.
Weil ich, glaube ich,
so 2000 Abonnenten hatte
und gar nicht wusste,
wie Funk überhaupt auf mich kam.
Schien aber nach 'ner seltsamen
und einmaligen Gelegenheit.
Deswegen dachte ich, ich mach das
jetzt einfach mal ein Jahr.
Und hatte vor, mir danach,
sowie die meisten Chemiker,
einen Job in der Industrie zu suchen.
Jetzt arbeite ich als Dozentin
fürs Navik, das ist kurz für das
"Nationale Institut
für Wissenschaftskommunikation".
Ich vermisse die Forschung
auf jeden Fall.
Was mir aber in der Forschung auch
immer gefehlt hat, ein bisschen,
war die Abwechslung,
die ich mir sonst halt immer
in meinen Hobbys gesucht habe.
Denn man wird schon
ein extremer Fachidiot.
Ich bin halt
ein sehr neugieriger Mensch.
Ich möchte wissen,
wie Dinge funktionieren.
Ich möchte Dinge verstehen.
Was einerseits schon sehr gut
zur Forschung passt -
andererseits möchte ich auch
ein breiteres Wissen haben
und interessiere mich
eben für verschiedene Sachen.
So dass mir meiner Arbeit im Moment
unglaublich viel Spaß macht.
Es gibt ein Videointerview von mir,
wo ich erkläre,
warum ich in die Wissenschafts-
kommunikation gegangen bin.
Viele fragen mich,
warum ich da nicht einfach
in der Forschung geblieben bin.
Verlink ich euch,
könnt ihr euch anschauen.
Dann mach ich natürlich YouTube
und wie ihr vielleicht auch wisst,
da auch verschiedene Sachen.
Und es gibt noch ein paar andere
Projekte, an denen ich arbeite.
Zu denen ich euch bei Gelegenheit
auch noch updaten werde.
2018 wird ein spannendes Jahr.
Werde ich euch noch alles erzählen,
beim nächsten Q&A.
Geht das Licht aus,
wenn die Kühlschranktür zu geht?
Also das ist
ziemlich einfach herauszufinden.
Ja! Ich mein, alles andere wär' jetzt
auch 'ne krasse Energieverschwendung.
Viele wollten jetzt natürlich wissen,
anlässlich der Flitterwochen,
wie ich Matthias kennengelernt habe.
Wir sind jetzt seit 9 Jahren zusammen
und der aufmerksame Zuschauer
kennt Matthias natürlich vom Sehen.
Weil er immer mal wieder
in meinen Videos kurz zu sehen ist.
Er ist nicht
unglaublich gerne vor der Kamera.
Aber wenn er gebraucht wird,
ist er natürlich da.
Wir haben uns damals im Studium
an der Uni Mainz kennengelernt.
Relativ am Ende des Studiums.
Er war ein Semester über mir.
Aber irgendwie kannten wir uns nicht
oder hatten uns nicht kennengelernt,
bis ganz zuletzt.
Und ich hatte mitbekommen,
dass er für ein Forschungsaufenthalt
ans MIT geht.
Also für alle Nicht-Nerds:
das MIT ist das Nerd-Paradies.
Es ist quasi ein Havard
nur für Naturwissenschaften.
Und deswegen natürlich
viel cooler als Harvard.
Natürlich wollte ich auch ans MIT.
Und wollte rausfinden,
wie er das geschafft hat,
und ob ich das
vielleicht auch schaffe.
Ich war auch schon immer so ein
bisschen sapiosexuell veranlagt
und dachte, wenn dieser Typ
ans MIT geht... Hallo!
Es stellte sich heraus,
der Typ ist nicht nur schlau,
sondern auch
mein Seelenverwandter.
Ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
eklig - aber es ist wahr.
Es war insofern
vielleicht nicht ganz optimal,
weil wir am Anfang
sehr viel Fernbeziehung hatten.
Wir lernten uns kennen,
kurz bevor Matthias für 7-8 Monate
nach Boston ging.
Und bis wir zusammenkamen,
hatte ich mir schon
meinen Forschungsaufenthalt
im Folgejahr organisiert.
Das heißt in den ersten
2 Jahren unserer Beziehung
war erst er 7-8 Monate in Boston und
danach war ich 8 Monate in Boston.
Aber Boston
ist so ein genialer Ort zum Forschen,
dass wir beide immer wieder
dahin zurück gegangen sind
und uns im Zuge dessen
immer besser synchronisieren konnten.
Also immer größere Überlappungen
hatten, im selben Land.
Und irgendwann dann nur noch
gemeinsam umgezogen sind.
Ja, und jetzt sind wir wieder
in Deutschland und verheiratet.
Oh Gott,
das wird ein so langes Video,
ich hoffe, euch interessiert
das überhaupt alles.
Deswegen zuletzt:
Vielen Dank
fürs Zuschauen bis hierhin.
Ich fühl mich total geschmeichelt,
dass ihr immer noch zuschaut jetzt.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
*Musik*